ein ganz besonders historischer moment
eine im moment sehr auch bei jedem sonst
noch so kontrollierten politiker der
sich immer darauf bedacht ist alles im
griff zu haben und auch so wenige
emotionen wie möglich raus zu lassen
irgendetwas bewirkt man muss einmal
mitnehmen es einmal mit auf die reise
beweist uns selbst auch dabei weißt du
wie so etwas abläuft was geht ab im
herzen was geht ab aber auch hinter den
kulissen ja es ist schwer bei olaf
scholz war ist ja nordisch by nature
ehrgeiz sehr mit seinen emotionen er
lässt nicht in sich hinein blicken aber
heute das konnten wir sehen ist ein
moment stolz da auch im moment
anerkennung für sich selbst für das was
er geleistet hat und auch natürlich ein
bisschen ja
zufriedenheit über den wagemutigen
gehabt das zu versuchen und es dann zu
schaffen das mischt sich allerdings jan
schäfer darauf hingewiesen mit den
aufgaben die kommen und kommen werden
das weiß er natürlich auch weil das
schon lange zeit in der regierung war
auch gerhard schröder das innen neben
dort erlebt hat also er ahnt was da
alles auf ihn zukommt was noch mal eine
spur mehr ist als einst finanzminister
jetzt fängt man da ja seinen ersten
arbeitstag an und weiß erst mal so
vieles nicht wie das eigentlich läuft ja
so war das auch hierbei bild am ersten
tag wie ist eigentlich jedes mit dem
mail system wer sagt mir eigentlich war
es wie sieht man sekretariat aus wie
komme ich dahin usw wo geht s in die
mensa der sagt heim all das im
kanzleramt ja da gibt es viele
hilfreiche geister wobei
olaf scholz da haben wir uns ja
getroffen war früher schon ich habe
ihnen dreimal in der woche im kanzleramt
getroffen hat neben also morgen
gespräche dauert bei frankfurt erst
einmal im büro also das war einst
präsident war natürlich alle der kennt
schon der wahl stellen auf welchen
aufzugs knopf man drücken muss um in die
oberste etage zu kommen und all so was
kennt ja auch aber es gibt natürlich
viele viele hilfreiche geister dort von
der leiterin der innen abteilung da im
grunde die glaube ich auch bleiben wird
und dann noch ein paar andere die viele
natürlich ihm das alles erklären und
wenn es denn was erkläre gibt aber ist
ein bisschen so als wäre der
vize-chefredakteur hier auf einmal
chefredakteur und der wusste auch wie es
mit dem messsystem ist wie ist das wenn
man im kanzleramt ist bela da gibt's
diesen schönen teppichboden man
schreitet dadurch und man könnte den
eindruck gewinnen dass die welt draußen
doch etwas weiter weg ist als sie
wirklich ist also ist das kanzleramt
möglicherweise auch dann mal schutz oder
ist es eher auch so dass man den den den
den bezug zur realität verliert also was
würdest du sagen was das bedeutet ist
jetzt aus dem kanzleramt zu regieren
würden in den bezug zur realität
verdienst du nie weil du ja auch immer
wieder raus muss raus willst raus muss
tatsächlich auch aus dem kanzleramt
daraus also es gibt ja niemand der sich
da verschanzen kann und gleichzeitig ist
es natürlich auch so dass du da drin
wenn du da drin ist nicht nur den
kontakt zur außenwelt hast aber
gleichzeitig auch als persönlichkeit
sehen muss dass erstmalig in touch
bleiben was mit den anderen aber was das
kanzleramt vor allen dingen ist und das
ist interessant es ist unglaublich ruhig
also es kann die größte krise seien im
kanzleramt erst eine ich will nicht
sagen gespenstische ruhe aber eine
erstaunliche ruhe ist nicht nur der
boden der alles weggefiltert sondern ja
ich weiß nichts eine anordnung der büro
ist oder was auch immer ist obwohl so
viele menschen dort arbeiten geht es da
immer sehr ruhig meistens auch gesittet
zu das ist gut weil es natürlich hektik
ist ja etr aufregung ist egal wir sehen
uns mit krone ab es werden noch viele
andere krisen kommen koalitionskräfte
unter gleichen und wenn da auch in
rheine wird durcheinander laufen würden
und krach machen würde wir können uns
vorstellen was da los ist nein das ist
schon sehr diszipliniert und wir sind
auch die besten beamten aus allen
verschiedenen ministerien dauert das
kann man wirklich sagen also ist schon
eine tolle tolle machtmaschine das wäre
es jetzt heute in den live bildern
gesehen im bundestag kam olaf scholz
kaum mehr freie war die ganze zeit
umgeben von einer menschentraube saves
wurden gemacht da konnten auch die
abgeordneten nicht an sich halten alles
wäre was das go gegeben hat so heute ist
fotografie im bundestag mal erlaubt
werden so oder so ähnlich auch die
kommenden tage für olaf scholz aussehen
also wird es so sein dass permanent am
freitag steht er auch seine erste
dienstreise an aber bis dahin permanent
jemand an die tür klopft und noch mal
hallo um noch einmal glückwunsch und
nochmal ein blumenstrauß und noch mein
kopf will survive vorbei zu bringen und
da gibt es auch da ein relativ klaren
ablauf auf jeden fall also jeder der
kann der ihm gratulieren kann oder denen
man nur so sieht der wird bestrebt sein
ihn noch enger an sich heran zu ziehen
also davor schützt olaf scholz natürlich
seine distanz die er selber hat aber das
wird erst mal die nächsten tage die
nächsten wochen vielleicht sogar die
nächsten monate sein denn neben diesen
persönlichen gibt es ja auch die
politischen ersten termine die erste
auslandsreise die ersten drehte der
europäische rat g7 uns weiter was alles
kommen wird immer ein erstes mal book
olaf scholz auf jeweils in diesen runden
einmal begrüßt werden wird nach einem
jahr ist das alles durch und
routine hat sich eingestellt und
spätestens dann aber auch schon viel
früher bitte ernst des regierens beginn
ein ja damals doch
und das ist der besondere moment auf den
wir warten oben rechts im bild sehen sie
das bild vom kanzleramt also der eine
zieht ein und die andere zieht aus
eigentlich sehr trauriger moment hier
denn sind hier nicht die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter anders
als sonst ist kanzleramt es dabei viele
im home-office auch über sind
tatsächlich angeschrieben worden das ist
diesmal keine
übergabe mit quasi denjenigen
dort arbeiten 750 jahren mittlerweile an
der zahl und
und deswegen eben eine große
enttäuschung mal es gibt da viele
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die 16
jahre lang mit angela merkel tatsächlich
dort waren auch damit ein bisschen die
haare da betreut hat und zugleich
natürlich noch mehr gemacht hat und so
war es nicht das sind alles natürlich
personen die jetzt gerne auf wiedersehen
gesagt hätten da wäre sicherlich auch
mal die eine oder andere träne geflossen
die müssen sich das jetzt alles zu hause
angucken das ist natürlich auch für
angela merkel selbst wie wird das glaube
ich sehr lästig sehen wird es schade
finden aber trotzdem den sehr
international damit umgehen also nicht
emotional aber
trotzdem schade für alle die die mit ihr
zusammengearbeitet haben ja wieder ein
neuer kanzler bringt ja eigene
mitarbeiter auch mit wolfgang schmidt
ist dass wir ihnen das beispiel als
kanzleramtsminister das ist ganz klar
wie viele mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter werden ausgetauscht weil ein
neuer kanzler sagt ich brauche meinen
eigenen stab ich brauche meine eigene
mannschaft ja das kann man noch nicht
vorhersagen es gibt ja die sogenannten
politischen beamten das sind im
kanzleramt auch die
abteilungsleiterinnen abteilungsleiter
dass irgend staatssekretäre wie der chef
des kanzleramtes beispielsweise das sind
auch solche leute wie staatsminister die
kommen ja alle neu carsten schneider ist
einer davon noch einige drei andere aber
im wichtig sind da die essenziell
wichtig sind die abteilungsleiter und
wir wissen ja dass ja cookies ehemaliger
goldman sachs manager und
deutschland-chef dann im
finanzministerium staatssekretär und
enger vertrauter von olaf schmidt
genommen wird von ihm er lässt sich
quasi zurückstufen weil die
abteilungsleiter position die dieser
goldman sachs man haben wird ist eine
stufe drunter so nimmt die sind die
gradierung auch wahrscheinlich wenn es
nicht ausgeglichen wird materiell in
kauf um zu sagen hier bin ich aber in
der schaltzentrale der macht bereite g7
gipfel vor
coach olaf scholz bei seinen wichtigen
wirtschaftspolitischen themen und und
der ist natürlich eine essenz die
anderen abteilungsleiter sind genauso
wichtig kann sein dass der einst war auf
ihren posten bleiben aber theoretisch
wäre es möglich gerade in den ruhestand
zu schicken